In yet another cue from nature, a German company has developed bionic butterflies...
...that look and fly like the real thing even in proximity to each other.
Weighing little more than an ounce but with a wingspan of around 20 inches,...
...each butterfly is equipped with two motors, two batteries, infrared markers...
...and wings made up of soft elastic material.
Designed as a technology research platform,...
...a demonstration shows them flying around a room,...
...installed with ten cameras, infrared tracking...
...and a central computer which coordinates their movement.
Several are in motion simultaneously at the same time,...
...and the real-time communications prevent potentially damaging collisions.
The devices were not developed to sell but represent continued research efforts...
...towards making ultralight networked robotic systems.